the work of HP Lovecraft has influenced
countless individuals and we still see
this influence today not only in the
cosmic horror genre but in horror itself
as well as in all kinds of strange
fiction one of his most universal ideas
was the Necronomicon a fictional
grimoire that features all sorts of dark
rituals magic and strange sciences now
there is the belief that a Necronomicon
may have once existed and it was merely
translated and published by Lovecraft
although this may not be true and lot of
it comes down to Lovecraft himself and
how alluring the idea was to others
there was a lot of history and lore
surrounding this particular grimoire
more so than some of Lovecraft's other
work he was also a fairly big proponent
to a shared universe and encouraging
other authors to expand upon his work if
they saw potential so when you have this
many authors mentioning a very specific
idea in this case the Necronomicon you
almost get the feeling that this idea
must have been real or at least rooted
in some kind of truth and I guess that
level of mystery and uncertainty is why
the Necronomicon was used by so many
even in modern day work that doesn't
necessarily tie into Lovecraft mythos
the owner of the book is a character
named abdullah al has read whom
Lovecraft refers to as the crazed Arab
al has read his first mentioned several
years prior to the Hound in the story
the nameless city but his association to
the Necronomicon is something we only
discover later when he was asked where
he drew his inspiration from Lovecraft
gave pretty much the most Lovecraft
answer possible he said it came to him
in one of his dreams and by now we know
pretty well that his dreams and
nightmares were quite weird to say the
very least
he states that the name Necronomicon was
translated from the Greek to mean an
image of the law of the Dead authors are
then subsequently followed have
translated it to mean a variety of
different things from book of laws of
the Dead to book of names of the dead
and even book of dead names so what we
can surmise from this at a very basic
level is that the neck
nomicon was designed to contain
information about the dead and the laws
that surrounded them which is quite
similar to the magical practice of
necromancy not only in premise but also
in name with how mysterious the
Necronomicon was in 1927 Lovecraft wrote
a short piece titled the history of the
Necronomicon which wasn't published
until after his death but this piece
gives us some additional history and
context we find out that the book was
originally called owl as if referring to
its Arabic origin the term Allah zeef is
what Lovecraft defined as that nocturnal
sound supposed to be the howling of
demons so we certainly get the idea that
this book isn't a beacon of happiness
and rainbows it's much darker and
nefarious the book was written by
abdullah al has read whom we mentioned
earlier but what we didn't mention was
that he worshiped yog-sothoth and
Cthulhu al hazzard himself was
originally from Yemen but it wasn't
until he visited Memphis Egypt that the
idea for the book began in Memphis he
came across the ruins of Babylon and the
underground secrets of the city where he
would discover the nameless city he then
spent the rest of his life living in
Damascus but we would recognize as
modern-day Syria shortly before his
mysterious disappearance in the year 738
he wrote al Aziz the Necronomicon the
book then began to circulate amongst
philosophers for the next 200 or so
years and in the year 950 it was
translated by the Greek philosopher
Theodorus Finnerty's and given the name
the Necronomicon
this version of the Necronomicon was
said to influence many individuals into
committing acts that were so terrible
they could barely be mentioned and that
is why the book was burnt in the Year
1058 react of Constantinople after this
the book wasn't really mentioned much
and when it was it was done so in secret
to avoid any unwanted attention from
those responsible for trying to erase it
from existence the book would then be
translated from Greek to Latin by a
Danish scholar in 1228 this edition
would be bound by the Pope but it
continued to resurface in other European
countries all the way up until the 17th
century
Lovecraft states that there are only
five copies of the original translated
Necronomicon held in five institutions
worldwide and these are as follows the
British History Museum in London the
bibliothèque nationale de France the
widen a library of Harvard University in
Cambridge Massachusetts the University
of Buenos Aires in Argentina the last
being in love crafts fictional town of
Arco Massachusetts in the Miskatonic
University which is also in possession
of the Latin translation now there are
of course other copies of the book in
circulation but these copies were pretty
much just copies of copies so how
authentic the contents are we don't
really know these copies were mostly in
the hands of private individuals so they
weren't easy nor cheap to get a hold of
so back story aside I'm sure the
question that most of you want answered
is what is in the book to make it so
taboo so dark that everyone who reads it
suffers a horrendous end we know the
book was written by someone who worship
the Elder Gods so as you can imagine
they make up quite a large part of
what's inside of the Necronomicon it's
full of strange symbols and arcane
knowledge that we can't really
understand and its content ranges from
stories to rituals and all kinds of
weird science in the story the thing on
the doorstep the book contains a formula
for one to transfer their conscious
yes the Dunwich horror contains a chant
that can summon york's are Thoth and
there are more than a few rituals that
can summon deities and all sorts of
creatures from love cross universe
inside as the name may suggest there is
also a chapter devoted to resurrect in
the dead one of the easiest ways to
describe the Necronomicon is as an
encyclopedia to all things Lovecraft
granted it's a very weird encyclopedia
that has a habit of killing anyone who
reads it but an encyclopedia nonetheless
it's also a detailed history of what
Earth may have been like aliens ago when
it was ruled and inhabited by creatures
and entities that we cannot even begin
to imagine I think what I like most is
despite the numerous times Lovecraft
mentions the book in his stories he
doesn't really describe the contents or
the appearance in great detail so it
does remain fairly mysterious which is
something that we don't really see too
much nowadays with everything being
spoon-fed to us the only thing we really
know is that it's a leather book bound
by metal and even then it's
intentionally missed titled sometimes to
keep it hidden in plain sight
this idea of being able to read the
Necronomicon without even knowing
creates a whole new horror concept in
itself the obsession of the Necronomicon
outside of fiction that i mentioned that
this start is no exaggeration there have
been and still are those who believe it
to be real and a number of hoaxes and
strange stories over the years is quite
astounding Lovecraft often received
letters from fans asking about the
authenticity of the book to which he
assured them it was purely fictional
this didn't stop some individuals from
listing the Necronomicon for sale in
local bookstores as well as creating
entries for the book in library
catalogues even going as far to say the
Vatican Library had a copy themselves
but most of this we can put down to
light-hearted pranksters and some crazy
people as the obsession continued to
grow in 1970 a book by the name of
Necronomicon was published by an author
under the pseudonym of Simon it would
later be dubbed Simon economic
the book itself doesn't really linked to
Lovecraft's work but instead claims that
it was influenced and based on Sumerian
mythology
this certainly blurred the lines between
fiction and reality with a book selling
over 800,000 copies as of 2006 so it
appears many of Love Cross fans were
intrigued enough by the premise to read
further it could also be because the
marketing for this book made some pretty
outrageous claims such as this book may
be the most dangerous black book of the
Western world regardless its success
meant that there were three additional
volumes published and I guess why not if
people wanted the major success of
Simon's Necronomicon led to the
publishing of the Necronomicon files in
1998 which aimed to finally prove that
the book was in fact a work of fiction
examining not only just Simon's version
of the Necronomicon but the many obscure
versions that followed in its success
whether or not you believe the
Necronomicon is real why certainly
understand the appeal of the book in a
fictional setting and why it would
attract so many different types of
people feel free to share your questions
and thoughts with me in the comments
below as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]